start being fathers start being men grow
a backbone I'm going to judge you you
need some harsh judgment here because
kids learn these things by what they see
not by what they see on your tax return
but by what they see in their household
namely are you there today everyone was
going nuts because President Obama spoke
on a panel at the poverty summit poverty
sir yeah it's always a summit you go
you've you pretty much have more than
you'll ever be able to use and your
family will ever be able to use context
here is important more than you'll ever
be able to use or your family will ever
be able to use in this context is
$300,000 that's what he's talking about
300 listen that's not nothing right I
mean people should be really happy if
you're blessed with $300,000 $300,000 in
the wrong neighborhood and Manhattan
gets you an apartment that you can't fit
into in a neighborhood it was your shame
to walk go there's a fairness issue
involved here and by the way if we were
able to close that loophole I can now
invest in early childhood education that
will make a difference that's where the
rubber hits the road I that's Arthur
where the question of compassion and I'm
my brother's keeper comes into play
compassion and I my brother's keeper
can you talk to Joe Biden he gave like
literally less than 1% of his own income
to charity left us don't give to
charities there's a great book who
really cares they don't you're talking
about compassion brother's keeper
what's compassionate about spending
somebody else's money go and if we can't
ask from society's lottery winners to
just make that modest investment this is
the most important one society's lottery
winners now leftists have accused
conservatives when they say Barack
Obama's a closet socialist or Marxist
and I agree that language can be
inflammatory but if
he was hiding in the closet he just saw
he just sashayed on out in his socialist
robe by calling the successful people in
the country society's lottery winners
really not by the way just for those of
you just tuning in these are talking
about actual lottery winners because
those people tend to invest very poorly
and don't tend to employ a lot of people
statistically it's poor people who play
the lottery who don't tend to make very
sound investments or business decisions
he's talking about wealthy people who
run businesses and likely employ you
didn't take hard work it didn't take
sacrifice it didn't take risk you just
won the lottery
Zuckerberg come on down let's tell him
what he wanted Plinko and secondly the
second that he said something was the
second thing that he said let's play it
to just make that modest investment okay
that was it just pay their modest amount
half even jon lovitz itself in a fight
democrat there was a big story I pay
half this whole thing the rich don't pay
their fair share is bold I pay half you
paying half I'm not just saying maybe we
can go to like tax him like ordinary
income which means that they might have
to pay a yeah true rate of around 23 25
percent I don't I don't know where he's
getting this number I don't know where
he's getting the marginal tax rates 2015
the highest bracket 39 percent that's if
you're making I think four hundred and
thirteen thousand will bring it up on
the screen he wants it to be well he
wanted it to be 250,000 now he's saying
three hundred thousand the marginal
federal tax rates the federal tax rates
are thirty nine percent I mean I don't I
may be talking about capital gains kind
of on people's that Romney didn't pay
enough for those of you don't understand
capital gains taxes you've already been
taxed on that money and then you've
invested that money
it's it's a second tax I I mean I don't
I don't know because even if you go
watch the whole video we'll have it at
ladder with Crider calm within context
it still nonsensical people people don't
like being poor and it's time-consuming
it's stressful it is it's hard and so
over time families frayed men who could
not get jobs left mothers who are single
or not able to read as much to their
kids so all that was happening 40 years
ago to African Americans I know I don't
know why fault and mothers can't read to
their kids it's important to read to
your kids okay listen this is a perfect
example of leftism versus conservatism
you look at you look at the Great
Society you look at Lyndon Johnson you
look at welfare laws you look at black
American families Barack Obama President
Obama knows this all too well has a
problem with fatherless households where
is it one time in this country they had
the strongest marriage rates they had
strong families and he looks at the
problem and says but we just we got it
we got to give them more stuff we're
gonna take stuff from the rich weak we
have to give people more stuff and
that'll solve the problem of fathers not
being accountable regardless of
community regardless of race instead of
saying let's look at this from a
personal responsibility angle and try
and get men to be husbands try and teach
men to be fathers instead of holding the
man accountable the government needs to
give them if the government just gave
them more stuff if they just took from
the people who have more money than you
could ever spend in a lifetime at
$300,000 oh I don't even know the median
home prices in a place like California
if we could just take from the people
who would never
able to spend that much money ever in
their life and give it to these families
well then the men wouldn't walk out it's
that kind of backwards thinking that
they use to justify taking money from
you to give it to someone who chose to
walk out on their family I am all for
values I'm all for character but I also
know that that character and that values
the values that our kids have that allow
them succeed and delayed gratification
and discipline and hard work that all
those things in part are shaped by what
they see what is more exemplary of what
children see then a fatherless household
notice he owes on all four values and
I'm all for character and integrity
let's get that out of the way but and
somehow it comes back to taking your
cash how about hey I'm all for values
I'm all for integrity
so fathers start being fathers start
being men grow a backbone I'm going to
judge you you need some harsh judgment
here because kids learn these things by
what they see not by what they see on
your tax return but by what they see in
their household namely are you there
some of those kids that they're not
going to get help at home they're not
going to get enough help at home and the
question then becomes or are we
committed to helping them instead okay
let me make this crystal clear I don't
believe for a second that the that the
federal government is committed to
helping these children as much as a
loving mother and father would be and if
I did I believe for even less of a
second for less than a whatever the
smallest nanosecond is that can be
measured unlike those those sound
machine tool used to measure dolphins
and the crazy Discovery Channel which is
awesome there's a sound coming from
Italy ocean we know what comes with
faith from yet okay whatever they use
for that whatever the shortest
nanosecond is that you could possibly
measure I believe for less than that
that the government is remotely capable
of providing that care for the
children go part of getting a good
education was getting soft skills not
just reading writing arithmetic but
cooperation and teamwork and so on and
part of that was that everybody in the
country got free access to
extracurricular activities bands and
football and music and so on but
beginning about 20 years ago the view
developed which is really really deeply
evil that that's just a frill that's
evil
Isis is burning Christians alive some
kid not being able to play as spit valve
in an oboe that's right catch your goat
that's okay by the way no one's saying
that these programs can't or shouldn't
be provided to kids the state can do
that the states have the right to do
that that way if they're providing
crappy programs and they're evil in
Texas you can go to Nevada where they
provide those programs no one's saying
that there shouldn't be public schools
libertarians aren't saying there
shouldn't be public schools they're
saying that states would no more
appropriately how to allocate those
funds in their local communities and the
federal government we've spent more on
education by the way these bumper
stickers it really but you know baby
today the Air Force has to take sale the
pie they're bombers in education gets
every dime it needs to be a best day in
America you see those bumper stickers
education spending in this country
outpaces the military it does overall
educational spending now it's not just
on the national level because a huge
portion of that comes from States and
comes from local municipal governments
no one's saying that you should do away
with with states having the right to
create public schools and so we
disinvested and we said if you want to
have you want to take part in football
here or you want to take part in music
you've got to pay for it okay here's the
myth you're poor people can't pay for it
I can go down to the local YMCA learn
judo guitar
basketball and underwater basket-weaving
for 4995 there are people who are
willing to provide those services and
guess what particularly if there's a
huge and growing market Thank You
President Obama of poor people if that
becomes a bigger sector of the
population and it seems like it's going
that way there will be more than enough
businesses looking to serve them if the
state municipal governments haven't
covered that already yeah and and of
course what that means is that poor
people can't pay for it's a big deal
$1,600 on average for two kids and a you
know in a family well $600 to play
football or you know playing the band or
a French club or whatever it's not a big
deal if your income is $200,000 but if
your income is $16,000 who in that right
mind is gonna be paying 10% of their
family income so I posit okay so listen
it's gonna get you long this is where
we'll end it notice the numbers he just
used he could have said when talking
about the wealthy talking about the
unfair gap he could have said a million
done he could've said ten million
dollars he could have said seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars he said two
hundred thousand dollars that's what he
chose that the context here is talking
about the highest marginal tax rates and
where they should come in and who can
afford which lottery winner can afford
to pay a moderately higher amount that's
the context here and that's where we
were ultimately taken because remember
this administration wanted to raise
taxes they wanted to lower the highest
tax bracket to two hundred fifty
thousand okay that was we're sending the
Bush tax cuts so the dog is growling
sorry so this is where we end up the
takeaway here is if you make two hundred
thousand dollars a year you are one of
society's lottery winners who can afford
to pay more than a moderate amount
what's a moderate amount you can afford
to pay more than half
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking my face and if you hated it
well join the club and you're gonna hate
this next video right next to me but
doesn't a part of you wanna know what it
is